hello everyone and welcome to a game
that went a relatively easy for one of
the players it's magnus carlsen versus
anish geary yeah and this is a game from
round four of the norway chess um uh
tournament it's from the classical
section so uh it's uh very very cool
that uh stuff like this happens in
classical games and now now you probably
know what i'm talking about as the the
game has pretty much been all over the
place already uh but let's dive straight
into it there is quite a lot to enjoy
magnus has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 all right sorry about that
we have knight to f6 by anish uh c for
e6 knight to f3 and d5 the queen's
gambit declined this on the board we
have knight to c3
and now c5 uh anish goes for the
semitarash we have c captures on d5 uh
and now well you could play this many
different ways e captures on the e5
knight captures and d5 anish goes for
the rarest and sharpest continuation
that is c captures on d4
and uh interestingly both magnus and
anish had this exact same position
against pragernanda only
with the black pieces so
it's very interesting how the game
continues so we've queen captures on d4
by magnus e compress on d4 and now uh
the story captures on d5 and the bishop
to g5 here the uh main idea is e4 or
rather the
most played movies e4 but here bishop to
g5 following the
game appregananda versus magnus carlsen
the ship to e7 we have e3 and now uh on
each castles with bishop to e2 knight to
c6 attacking the queen queen d3 and now
h6 challenging the bishop also creating
a little bit of breeding room for the
black king here bishop to h4 and now the
ship to e6 developing and defending the
pawn on d5
castles by magnus and then now comes
queen to b6 and we actually reach the
position uh pragananda had against
magnus carlsen in the esports cup this
year
uh that uh magnus won and in that game
a3 was played idea being that of course
the queen cannot capture here as the the
queen would just get trapped uh but um
like i said indian magnus continued to
win that game and this is a known idea
uh but the move magnus plays uh is a new
move he plays bishop captures on f6 here
it's one of the engine's top
recommendations so magnus uh
improved a little bit
over his game against pragananda with
the white pieces so here we have bishop
captures on f6 and now knight captures
on d5 attacks the queen so you have to
capture bishop captures on d5 queen
captures and queen captures on b2
grabbing upon equalizing in material and
now as you see anish has two to one uh
advantage on the queen side and that is
definitely something that you can play
for especially with a very strong brush
up here controlling the
this diagonal also the a1 square so
could be a very very important in the
long run but here after bishop the c4
a most interesting uh move happens it is
actually the one from the thumbnail here
anish just played queen captures on a1
he gives up the queen for two rooks
which is usually a very good idea the
problem in this position is that it just
loses by force uh so here the the safer
queen to a3 is the way to go because the
queen really doesn't have all that many
squares once rook to b1 is played you're
going to have
problems so queen a3 for example and
after let's say rook 8 to d1 now we just
go after the bishop knight to a5 bishop
to d3 and now we play g6 so one of the
ways that that you you can actually play
this now the point is uh of course it
seems like you can just play bishop
captures on g6 here but there's rook a
to d8 and then everything is perfectly
fine so uh that that's the idea however
here queen captures an a1 was played and
this would uh this would be great if it
was not losing by force rook captures
queen we have bishop captures on a1 and
now magnus needs to find the move and a
very very particular move is needed here
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that
even though anish does have two rooks
for the queen his two rooks are
currently doing nothing so magnus really
needs to just hurry up with the attack
and that is exactly what he does so
congratulations to everyone who found
this and that is pawn to g4
we want to play g5 bust open the
position and try and checkmate the black
king as soon as possible and now magnus
really took his time here and i i first
i thought magnus was thinking here for
like an hour and 20 minutes then i just
realized that the website where i was
watching uh was malfunctioning and that
you know everything was still except the
timer so i don't know how long he was um
thinking about this move but i'm pretty
sure it was it was quite some time maybe
even half an hour if someone has the
exact time magnus was thinking about
this move uh do share in the comments i
will i will pin it for everyone to see
uh but here anish goes rook 8 to e8
you'd expect rook 8 to d8 attacking the
queen but still after queen to f5
there's just um not all that much you
can play here now g6 is never an option
because just queen captures on g6 will
be played and that's uh that's a problem
uh so instead after this g4 move we have
rook eight to e8 and now magnus
continues with h4
now this h4 move is uh very very
interesting because uh
g5 is sort of the move you want to play
but it if it if it doesn't win by force
maybe it's important to include h4 but
just to give you an example as it's a
it's it's a very forced line uh for
example g5h captures on g5 knight
captures now you have a triple attack on
this f7 square we're gonna play rook to
e5 now attacking the queen
and the knight queen the g2 defending
the knight and now rook to c5 putting
pressure on the bishop there isn't a
better move for black now queen to g4
and after knight to a5 going after the
bishop here we're gonna switch the
bishop over to this diagonal and now
after rook after c8 we finally get the
queen to the h file and now we are
bringing the queen to h7 but here let's
say rook eight to c7 queen h7 checking
to f8 now there's really no better move
for white as our knight is hanging than
to just play h4 so as this move will
have to be played at some point and
there's no way to continue the actual
attack without playing this move uh
magnus just starts with h4 instead of
going g5 right away so here he plays h4
rook to e7 adding another defender here
and now pawn to g5 we have captures on
g5 by anish and then now knight captures
and g5 and this
knight captures and g5 is actually not
the most precise uh way to play this
queen to f5 is uh because this now uh
stops g6 which is definitely what you
want to play and after knight to e5
attacking the knight and the bishop we
just play knight captures on g5
threatened checkmate here and after g6
as now it can be played as the knight
covers g6 now we play queen to f6 we
attack the rook and after rook to d7 uh
now we play bishop to b5 and now after
uh
a lot of moves have been played we are
going to play bishop to e8 at some point
and uh uh must open the position here
because the it will be impossible to
develop
a defend df7 square to give an example
it's say rook d1 check king g2 rook b1
we go after the bishop bishop gets
defended then we're gonna play rook to
b4 uh threaten uh the dh4 pawn now king
h3 defended and now after a6 as black is
really without a move uh we're going to
play queen to e7 attack the rook and
grab control over the e8 square and once
the rook moves doesn't really matter
where we're going to play bishop to e8
put pressure on f7 and now uh
we are just busting through there's
there's no good way of tackling this for
example a rook to h1 we can even give up
the h4 pawn king g2 rook captures here
we're gonna play bishop capture sun f7
knight captures and now for example
knight to e6 and there is no good way to
to play this this is only one
one of the lines that that wins but many
others are winning as well so here
instead of going for queen to f5 magnus
plays knight captures and g5 right away
similar but not as forcing because now
anish just plays bishop to f6 and this
is a very very nice um uh defensive idea
queen to f5 again making it impossible
to play g6 as now the bishop would hang
so bishop captures on g5 pretty much the
only move your
checkmate is being threatened bishop
captures h captures in the rookie five
now attacking the queen queen f4 keeping
an eye on the g5 pawn and now comes rook
the c5 and this is just uh uh
resigns basically rook to e7 still holds
the game a little bit but still after g6
it's um
not a pretty pretty position to defend
because after 95 adding a defender here
for example captures captures you are
never unpinning from this you you can't
move the knight if you move the king
then queen h4 check or or queen
somewhere check is just um
it's just uh
pointless to play this with black
there's just no no moves you can make so
instead anish plays rook to c5 but now
just g6 and now again magnus is just
breaking through 95 we have g captures
on f7 knight captures and the bishop to
e6 now it's important to keep the
tension here rook to h5 and now queen to
c7 now magnus will just gobble up the
queen side pawns uh g5 banish
looking for some counter play queen
captures and now rook to h6 attacks the
bishop magnus just brings the bishop
back keeps an eye on this diagonal uh g4
and now queen captures on a7 and now we
have another uh advantage uh here on the
queen side that we don't have to play on
the attack anymore we can just start
pushing the pass pawn and we are going
to win this so king g7 e4 by magnus we
have rook to h5 and now queen to c7 king
qf6 we have a4 and he was in this
position after magnus pushed a4 on move
34 that anish geary resigned the game
and a very nice victory for magnus in
the um
round four of the norwegian classical
edition so here you resign because
there's no way to actually stop the pawn
uh
or you know even play a move you can't
move the road because the knight is
hanging if you're not careful we're just
gonna deliver a check and pick up one of
the pieces
let's say you try 95 we can play queen
d6 check now if you go here we pick up
the knight if you don't defend the rook
we pick up the we pick up the rook so
there's that uh you have to defend it
and now queen e7 check knight f7 the
only move that doesn't lose a heavy
material now bishop d5 now the rook no
longer defend
attacks the square now we push the pawn
and win the game
so that's basically how we would do it
so very nicely done by magnus it was a
it was a very nice idea by anish to go
for this uh queen captures on a1 uh like
i said the only problem is that it loses
by force if magnus uh spots the the g4
idea and the magnus spotted a g for g5
or rather g4 h4 g5 and that's how you uh
you win this because if you allow anish
to bring the rooks into the game then
it's not going to be
possible to push
so hard but here as the rooks were still
undeveloped uh the two rooks for the
queen was not a good idea in this
position
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it um even when it looks
like it should be possible uh sometimes
it just isn't that's one of the beauties
of chess i would like to thank valenti
moreira and legend varun sudarsanan
richard knapp and raymond young for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
norway chess until it finishes uh so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
we are going to check out the standings
but after we show a few more games from
round four uh see you soon